you work very late hours mr. Queen
pudding killing back on the table is a
huge step backwards that's not what she
would have wanted the dead don't want
anything if you hit me again I'm gonna
kill you
it's not paying them praise be its fear
SCPD thinks that these murders might be
the works of a different vigilante it's
just me out there I can't do it mama
I'm recruiting a new team they're
already out there Oliver because
inspired by you I'm Curtis
Evelyn sharp there's a weight this
training get past me ring that Bell so
we're playing games now
I have no family
I have no home I have no name
you're up flat
[Music]
who are you the green arrow is mine
arrow season premiere Wednesday 8:00
7:00 central on the CW hey youtubers
it's Charlie so new arrow trailer we
finally get a look at Dolph Lundgren he
is going to break Oliver it's gonna be
so much fun we're gonna make all the
jokes this trailer is way better than
all the previous arrow trailers the tone
of the music just gives you an idea for
the tone of the first couple of episodes
where we pick up with Oliver killing so
to speak is back on the table
Laurel wouldn't have wanted that the
dead don't want anything
you also get teasers for the Bratva in
the flashbacks and we finally see Dolph
Lundgren he's basically the big villain
of the flashbacks as you would want him
to be he is going to break Oliver it's
gonna be the rocky training montage
he-man versus Skeletor battle royale of
our dreams but we also get to hear
Prometheus speak at the very end of the
trailer he or she like we should you
know gender nonspecific has Tobias
Church Tyrese himself who's like the
biggest dude ever on his knees who are
you the green arrow is mine so the way
they modulated the voice sounds like it
could either be a woman or a man the
shots that they've included of the
character in the trailers so far have
been like you know very weird angles so
you just you can't really tell from the
way they stand of the way they walk you
guys can let me know like do you think
that Prometheus could be a woman
normally you'd assume that it's like a
really big tall hulking man that's like
just as tall as Stephen Amell and
Stephen Amell is like a little over six
feet so he's pretty tall but it's not
like the Tony Todd zoom voice where
you're like this is definitely a man
speaking like you definitely recognize
Tony Todd's voice and that kind of lets
you know that zoom is a man but the
Prometheus character in the comic books
is a male character so you kind of
assume going into this when they
announced the Prometheus was going to be
the big bad that it would be a dude
from season 1 it would be some deep cut
like oh my god somebody's come back to
make Oliver pay for everything he's done
but we'll probably get some more clues
in the first couple of episodes
I'm not expecting them to reveal too
much too soon but just like the way
they've cut this trailer makes it look
like there's just a bunch of big action
set-pieces in the first couple of
episodes way more than you would think
before like it's more built around that
type of storytelling they call it Game
of Thrones storytelling because it's
like event based programming each week
like each new episode is a big event
it's not just like a bunch of big
characters standing around talking to
each other or like a bottle episode
where they're all trapped inside the
arrow cave for an entire hour but we get
a better look at the new team arrow we
see wild dog unleashing like Felicity
has that line where she's like all these
vigilantes have been inspired by you
they're already out there Oliver wants
to put a new team together in that sharp
tip that Quentin has looks like it might
be from Prometheus maybe that's part of
his arc this season remember the early
days of Quentin's storyline he was just
committed to taking the vigilante down
he was obsessed with Oliver thought that
he was the vigilante then that was like
a whole big thing for the first couple
of seasons so now maybe part of his art
is in tracking down this other vigilante
like they say the SCPD thinks that this
is the work of another vigilante so the
thing about that is though is that
Oliver seems like he's gonna be dropping
bodies via the new vigilantes like wild
dog who joined team arrow also look like
they're dropping bodies or you know we
don't see him kill anyone but we see him
draw those guns it's just you see all
these dead bodies so I'm guessing that
these are from Prometheus and the other
like one of my other favorite lines from
the trailer is actually what they open
with where you hear that female voice
say you work very late hours mr. Queen
so one it sounds like somebody inside
Oliver's mayoral team someone inside
that office is trying to cozy up to him
but to obviously he's leading the double
life where he's the mayor during the day
doing all the political stuff then at
night he's the green arrow putting
killing back on the table
let's see other new stuff so David
Nichol is back the actor is back he
plays cagey beast from the comics
although they haven't called him cagey
beasts so they might give the actual
cagey beast name to another character we
don't really know the name of Dolph
Lundgren's character but the real-life
name of David Nicholls character is
cagey beasts in the comics so I don't
know if they're going to change that but
we
also see more of zombie Cody Rhodes we
see a little bit more of dig helping
train the new team we see Thea and her
costume I don't really know what her
status is going to be this year because
her big thing last year was that she
would not continue to be a vigilante so
maybe she's flying solo we see
Felicity's new boyfriend they've teased
him like we'll beat him in the first
couple of episodes we know about the
four night crossover you may not have
read it but there's a storyline in the
comics from the 80s written by Todd
McFarlane the guy who created spawn
called invasion and it's basically the
dominators invading earth that's going
to be the MacGuffin of the four night
crossover now because Supergirl is still
on a different earth she's going to be
the beginning of that crossover she'll
see like the first steps of it then
it'll be a much bigger thing on flash
arrow in legends of tomorrow you don't
really know how it's going to play out
we only know that the multiverse is
going to be involved and it also adds to
the theory that during the arrow 100th
episode which is like the arrow part of
the four-night crossover will be earth
to robert queen who's the green arrow of
his earth the other really cool thing is
that the title of that big comic book
arc is invasion with an exclamation
point so obviously one of the titles of
the episodes is going to be invasion
with the exclamation point they revealed
that the title of the arrow 100th
episode has an exclamation point at the
end of it so I'm guessing arrow episode
8 will be titled invasion it'll be like
the big climax like you know typically
in a big story you have the first act
introduction you have the second act
build you have a third act climax then
you have a fourth act conclusion so
think about each of the four shows in
that way meaning the arrow would be like
the big third act climax of the
four-night crossover and they'd resolve
it the conclusion would be on the fourth
night on legends of tomorrow right after
that but like Stephen Amell has been
posting pictures from the arrow part of
the crossover we see him standing next
to Supergirl here on this rooftop in
Vancouver the skin the schedule has been
very reasonable to schedule for the
crossover is basically like for the
crossover I read all of the scripts
three times and then I basically lived
one day at a time
where they just tell me where I'm going
because I'm vacillating between shows
yesterday I was on legends and then I
was on flash and I got to do a scene
with Victor Garber not saying I'm which
show and you know Grant nice working
with Grant so what kinds of crazy shits
gonna be happening I'm expecting more
flash trailer stuff to drop in the next
day or so so depending on what more we
learn about the crossover I'll do a
separate video about that but I'm really
excited
I think the dominators are a good start
in a future season they could do
something even crazier they could do one
of the crisis like crisis on Infinite
Earths or Infinite Crisis as a way to
combine supergirls
earth with Oliver & berriz earth 1 if
you are confused about which earth is
which earth one is the earth that we've
been viewing on the TV shows this whole
time earth 2 is the one that introduced
during flash last season birth 3 is
where Jay Garrick is from and they
haven't officially said which earth
Supergirl is on and I'm hoping that they
actually just combined her earth with
Jay Garrick's earth in Jay Garrick is
the way she gets to Oliver and buries
earth because the only characters we've
seen so far that can travel the
multiverse are Flash family people like
zoom could do it Barry could do it Jay
Garrick could do it so it sounds like
you have to have the Speed Force in this
universe to travel between earths so
maybe Jay Garrick or maybe Barry
somebody goes and gets her and brings
her to earth otherwise I don't think
she'd be able to do it by herself but
we'll probably find out pretty soon so
later today
new flash posting so be sure to
subscribe to get it there's new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so that should post in the
next couple of hours get hype it is
gonna be awesome I'm so excited about
all this what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my Fight
Club trailer video and you can click
here for my arrow 100th episode video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight